قال قائد عسكري ميدانيه في قوات ايفنا
الروسيه لقواته تخوض معارك وصفها بالعنيفه
للغايه وتحقق التقدم في محور مدينه باخمود
في شرق يوكانيا ووضح في تصريحات الله بان
قوته تعمل على توسيع مساحه وطول جبهه
المعارك مع الجيش الاوكرانيه حول المدينه
من جهه اكدت السلطات ودنيتك المواليه
لروسيا مشاركه قوات فاجنر في هجمات
بالدبابات وراجمات الصواريخ على مواقع
الجيش الاوكراني في بخموت
واعلنت رئاسه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن صدق
قواتها 11 محاولات لتقدم من القوات
الروسيه
اوكرانيا وقالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيا
القوات الروسيه الخاصه
صواريخ واكثر من 40 حديثا جانبيه قال حاكم
مقاطعه الاوكرانيه ان مدنيا قتل اصيب
ثمانيه اخرون في قصر استهدف عده مدن وبلده
في المقاطعه
الان ينضم الينا منك كراماتسكا مراسل
الجزيره عامر لافي ومن دنياتك مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي يرحب بكما دمعك عامر
وهذه المحاولات للتقدم التي يعلن عنها
الجانب الاوكراني ويعلن انه قام بصددها ما
طبيعتها ومدى يعني تاثيرها ايضا
مع محمد يعني تعلم ان الجبهه الشرقيه هي
الجبهه الاعلى في عموم اوكرانيا ومحاولات
التقدم الروسيه لا تتوقف على طول خطوط
المواجهه في تونس وفيلوغاز وبالتالي هي
محاولات يوميه تتحدث هذه الاركان عنها في
بيانها اليومي وتوضح مدى يعني
التركيز الروسي على هذه المحاور وتعلم ان
قياده الاركان اوروبا منذ اربعه ايام وهي
تتحدث عن نقل جنود روس من هؤلاءك الذين
انسحبوا من غير سون الى هذه الجبهه وهو ما
يشير الى ان هذه الجبهه ال- ال- المستعره
اصلا واضح انها ستزداده استعارا وستكون
المعارك اكثر شراسه كما ذكرت تتحدث عن
عشره محاولات الروسيه للتقدم ومحاوله في
لوغاز طبعا وتبقى طبعا تحافظ
على الزخم الاكبر في هذه المحاولات مخموط
طبعا واضح ان هناك محاولات روسيه كويسه
جدا للسيطره على هذه المدينه مصادرنا التي
تحدثنا معها صباح اليوم تحدثوا عن ان هناك
محاولات مركزه في المحور الجنوبي لهذه
المدينه وتحديدا عند بلدتي كورد ما يفكا
وكلاشيكا هتل بلدتين تقع عن جنوب مخمود
هناك محاوله لتقدم وتحد وحديث عن ان هناك
تقدم وان كان طفيفا للقوات الروسيه هناك
لكن في المقابل تقول هذه المصادر بانه
خسائر كبيره سقطت في صفوف الجنود الروس
يتحدثون عن اعداد كبيره من القتله يقولون
بان ساحه المعركه مليئه بالشفاء قوات
اتفاقنار هي التي تقود المعارك هناك في
محمود وبالتالي يعني لا احد يتمكن من سحب
هذه
لكثره همم المعارك هناك والاشتراكات
الموجوده على بخمود ايضا طبعا محمد
المدينه طبعا تقصف بشكل يومي على سبيل
المثال اليوم في البيان اليومي لحاكم الذي
تحدث عن مقتل مدني واصابه ثمانيه مدنيين
يعني هذا الذي قتل قتل في هذه المدينه
مدينه بخمود واصيب ثلاث مدنيين في القصف
المستمره على هذه المدينه
حاكم الاوكراني قال نعم انا اعتذر منك فقط
لان الوقت باخلاء العديد من المدرب بسبب
القصف الذي لا يتوقف شكرا
الذي يقود هذه العمليه من اجل السيطره على
مدينه مخبوط كما ايضا يشارك في عدد من
المعارك بمحاور مختلفه شمال من صفاتها
بمقاطعه لوجان
في همم لكن الحديث عن همم تحقيق تقدم على
الارض ايضا يتطابق هذا الحديث من قبل
روسيا
قد تحدث عنه قبل نحو ثلاثه ايام لكن يبدو
ان هذا التقدم بطيء للغايه باعتبار ان
العمليه
اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر وحتى الان القوات
الروسيه لم تدخل حتى الى الاحياء الجنوبيه
او الغربيه من المدينه اليوم
لروسيا في لوكا قالوا بانها القوات
الاوكراني يتخلى عن خطتها لشن هجوم واسع
على مقاطعه لوغانس بعد ما قالوا انها
خسائر كبيره لحقت القوات الاوكرانيه
المهاجمه هناك ايضا تعذر وصول الدعم
العسكري من همم يعني من قذائف ويعني ذخائر
وما الى ذلك هنا في دنياك امس الرئيس
لروسيا قال بان القوات الاوكرانيه دفعت
بعد عدد كبير من قواتها الى محيط مدينه
دونيسكو تحديدا من قوات الاحتياط وقلبي
انها لا تكسريه بحجم الخسائر التي تتكبدها
قواتها وانها تحاول همم التقدم وصد في
المقابل في الهجمات او الهجمات الروسيه
على محاور خاصه في جنوب دنيا اسكو ايضا في
اف ديفكا طبعا كل هدايا همم يدور طبعا
بتوازي مع التواصل القصف على مدينه حيث
اعلنت السلطات اليوم هنا عن تعرض حقيقي
القوات الاوكرانيه به